[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم وتقبل الله صومكم تحفظت
النيابه العامه الفلسطينيه على اموال
جمعيه فلسطين الغد الخيريه تابعه لرئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني السابق سلام فياض وذكرت
مصادر لوكاله الانباء الرسميه وفا ان قرار
التحفظ هذا على حسابات المؤسسه جاء نتيجه
معلومات تم تقديمها للنيابه العامه بشان
شبهات حول اداره المال لاهداف سياسيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما
هي الاسباب الحقيقيه وراء التحفظ على
اموال مؤسسه فلسطين
الغد واي علاقه لهذه الخطوه بتطلعات
وصراعات سياسيه تطرق ابواب السلطه
[موسيقى]
الفلسطينيه منذ استقالته عام
2013 من رئاسه الحكومه الفلسطينيه توارى
سلام فياض عن الانظار وامتنع عن الفعل
السياسي المعلن حاسرا نشاطه في العمل
الاجتماعي غير انه منذ ايام اعادت السياسه
لملاحقه فياض مجددا وبات اسما في الاخبار
بعد ان قررت النيابه العامه الفلسطينيه
التحفظ على اموال جمعيه فلسطين الغد التي
يراسها وبين الصمت الرسمي حول هذه الخطوه
واعتبار فياض ان كل اجراءات مؤسسته
قانونيه يرى مراقبون ان ما حدث هو بدايه
تكتلات في سياق خلافه الرئيس محمود عباس
تقرير جفار
البديري بعد ان غادر منصب رئيس الحكومه
الفلسطينيه الذي شغله بين اعوام 2007
و23 عقب خلافات مع الرئيس الفلسطيني وحركه
فتح يعود سلام فياض الى الواجهه فقبل ايام
ابلغ من قبل بنك فلسطيني بقرار النائب
العام الحجز على اموال مؤسسه فلسطين الغد
التي انشاها قبل عامين وقد اكد فياض
للجزيره انه يتم نشر الاصول الماليه بشكل
دوري وعلني وان ما يتم تداوله من اتهامات
تتعلق بغسل الاموال هو محض افتراء والدليل
هو حجم المشاريع التي نفذتها المؤسسه
ونوعها التركيز على كل ما من شانه ان يدعم
قدره المواطن الفلسطيني على الاستمرار في
الصمود والبقاء والثبات على الارض في وجه
الاحتلال في القدس في المناطق سم الجين في
الاغوار وفي كافه المناطق المحدده من وال
متضرره من الجدار والاستيطان والمحدد
المزيد من ذلك بالاضافه لما قامت به
فلسطين الغد في عام 2014 ابان العدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه باطلاق حمله
اغاثه فال المؤسسه تؤكد انها تمكنت من
تنفيذ اكثر من 114 مشروعا لدعم التنميه
المستدامه حاولت الجزيره الحصول على رد من
النائب العام الا ان الطلبه قوبل بالرفض
بينما صرح مصدر امني مسؤول ان القرار هو
نتاج معلومات حول اداره ما وصفه بالمال
السياسي مصطلح لم يسمع من قبل ولكنه كلمه
السر لحل اللغز وفق ما يراه مراقبون لكون
الدعم هو من دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده التي تربطها علاقات وثيقه
بالقيادي المفصول من حركه فتح محمد دحلان
يدل على ان الامر له علاقه بالصراعات
السياسيه والخلافات حول الوضع السياسي
القائم وصراع حول خليفه الرئيس وهناك
بالتالي بدايه يعني تكتلات وحشود الصراعات
الداخليه وان بقيت في الخفاء الا ان ما
يظهر منها يدل على انه لا ضمانات في
السياسه وان قاده كل الفصائل يتناسون ان
هناك شعب هو من يختار قادته عبر صناديق
الاقتراع جفار بديريه الجزيره رم المحتله
ونرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من نابلس
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي حسن سليم ومن رام
الله هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث
السياسات لو بدانا برام الله سيد هاني
المصري هل تبدو هذه الاتهامات بغسيل اموال
او توظيف المال السياسي ايه
مقنعه ايه لا تبدو مقنعه وخاصه انه لم
يصدر عن النائب العام اي تصريح يوضح ما
جرى وهذا من حق الراي العام الفلسطيني ان
يعرف ماذا حدث ولماذا هذا الاجراء بل اكثر
من ذلك الذي تحدث بعد ان وضح سلام فيار ان
هذا اجراء يعني جائر وان مؤسسته تقوم ب
معاملاتها بشكل قانوني صرح ردا على ذلك
مصدر امني مسؤول ما علاقه الامن بهذا
الموضوع من الطرف الذي يجب ان يوضح هو
النائب العام والنيابه العامه ايضا يعني
الاجراء
اتخذ اجراء عالي منذ اللحظه الاولى وبدون
ان يصدر عن محكمه يعني حجز اموال مؤسسه
وخاصه هذا الحجز تمدد اكثر من مره
والابلاغ الاخير صدر عن محكمه لكي يتم
لمده غير محدده هذا يمكن ان يؤدي الى
انهيار المؤسسه لان المؤسسه تقوم باجراءات
و عليها التزامات واذا تم حجز الاموال
لفتره طويله بدون ان يصدر اي حكم يمكن ان
تنهار وبالتالي يترتب عليها اعباء وديون
يعني المساله الاساسيه ان العدل اساس
الملك والحكم وان كل انسان كل متهم بريء
حتى تثبت ادانته ولا اقول ان هذا الكلام
دفاعا عن سلام فياض فانا لست معروفا
بتاييد سلام فياض عندما كان رئيسا للحكومه
بل انا بالعكس كنت معارضا كبيرا لسياسه
وبرامجه وخاصه فيما يتعلق ببرنامج بناء
المؤسسات واثبات الجداره كطريق لانهاء
الاحتلال واقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه كذلك
السياسات الاقتصاديه
وحتى يعني الانتهاكات التي ارتكبت في عهده
ضد حقوق الانسان وضد المؤسسات انا كنت ضد
هذه الاجراءات في تلك الفتره وضدها الان
لاننا
يحسان وان نحترم القانون واي اجراء يجب ان
يكون بشكل قانوني نعم موضوع اداره مال
سياسي او غسيل اموال او او غيرها سيد حسن
سليم يعني ليست معروفه في الوسط الفلسطيني
ان ان ان تتهم بها مؤسسه فلسطين الغد كيف
تنظر الى هذا النوع من الاتهامات
[موسيقى]
يعني بدايه سيدي كريشان لابد من توضيح
عديد من المسائل قبل الدخول بتفاصيل
القضيه القضيه الاولى ان الحديث يجري ليس
عن جمعيه خيريه الحديث يجري عن شركه غير
ربحيه وهناك فرق في القانون من حيث الاساس
القانون للترخيص وبين ايضا المتابعه الفرق
كبير بين شركه غير ربحيه وبين جمعيه خيريه
الموضوع الثاني معروف وفق قانون الاجراءات
الجزائيه ان التحقيق سري وان المحاكمه
علنيه بالتالي من حق النيابه العامه
الاحتفاظ بالكتمان على اسرار التحقيق لحين
الانتهاء منه ومن ثم اطلاع الجمهور عليه
الامر الثالث يعني كنت افضل ويا حبذ لو
كان هناك من يمثل شركه فلسطين الغد حتى
يحدث الجمهور عن الاساس الذي تم على تم
الاعتماد عليه في التحفظ على اموال هذه
الشركه بالتاكيد كما تفضل استاذ استاذ
هاني يعني هناك خطوره كبيره اذا تم وضع
الجميع تحت الشبهات ولكن من حق المؤسسه
سواء كانت الامنيه او من حق السلطه
التنفيذيه ان تتخذ ما يلزم من اجراءات من
اجل حفظ النظام العام من اجل التاكد من
سلامه مصدر هذه الاموال التي تدخل الى
البلد وايضا من سلامه الهدف الذي تدخل
اليه هناك اشكاليه كبيره في تعلق بعمل
الخيه بعمل القطاع اذك بعد اذنك سييد سليم
على ذ على ذكر المصدر
والهدف يبدو ان مربط الفرس في كل القضيه
على ما يبدو واقول على ما يبدو انها
الاموال تاتي من الامارات وان لها علاقه
بمحمد دحلان وبالتالي نظر اليها سياسيا
وليس باعتبار اي شيء اخر هل تميل الى هذا
النوع من ال من
التحليل يعني بصراحه اشفق على الدكتور
سلام فياض من حيث توريطه في هكذا قصه
الدكتور سلام هو رجل محترم هو رجل دوله
رئيس وزراء لسنوات اكثر من خمس الى ست
سنوات بالتالي ان يتم ادخاله في معمعان
الصراع السياسي الداخلي موضوعه الامارات
وموضوع هذا المفصول او ذاك بالتالي اشفق
عليه ولكن كما ذكرت من حق النيابه العامه
ان تتاكد ان هذه الاموال التي دخلت الى
حسابات شركه فلسطين الغد مصدرها مشروع
ويتم الصرف في الاطار المشروع في البلد
البلد لا يمكن ان تكون مشاع من حق النظام
النظام السياسي مهما كانت صفته ان يتاكد
من مشروعيه الا الاوال التي تدخل اليه
وللتذكير فقط في عهد الدكتور سلام فياض في
في 22 اب 2007 تم حل 1003 جمعيات السبب
كان ان هذه الجمعيات تعمل لاهداف واغراض
سياسيه بالتالي لماذا محرم على النظام
السياسي ان يقوم بمحاكمه او اتخاذ ما يلزم
من مقتضى قانوني ولكن محلل للاخرين ان
يعملوا بشكل معاكس القانون قانون غسل
الاموال الذي تم اصداره في العام 2007
ويحمل رقم تسعه تم صدوره بتنسيب من
الدكتور سلام فياض بالتالي من حق السلطه
التنفيذيه ومن حق القضاء ان يقول كلمته
حتى اللحظه الاجراء المتخذ هو اجراء تحفظي
بمعنى لم يكون هناك قرار قطعي وفي في ذات
الوقت هناك اجراءات وهناك تحقيق مشغول
لحين البث في هذه القضيه وبالتالي من حق
الجمهور في اثناء المحاكمه الاطلاع على
حيثيات القضيه وللتاكد ان كان هناك فعلا
لدينا قضاء نزيه ان ان هناك تدخل في عمل
القضاء او ان كان هناك صله بين اموال سلام
فياض والامارات وكما ذكرت علاقه او باخرى
مع محمد دحلان نعم في انتظار ان يبت
القضاء بشكل واضح سيد هاني المصري الجمعيه
الجمعيه ليست جديده جمعيه فلسطين الغد
ليست جديده والتحويلات اليها اكيد ليست
جديده بتقديرك مصدر هذه الاموال وشخصيه
دحلان التي ذكرت في سياق هذا التحويل
برايك هذا عنصر جديد اثر في طبيعه القرار
المتخذ ضد
الجمعيه اولا اسمح لي ان اوضح الحديث عن
تبييض الاموال يكون صحيحا لو كانت الجهه
التي حولت المبالغ غير معروفه الجهه التي
حولت المبالغ هي الهلال الاحمر الاماراتي
وهي جهه معروفه وتمول مشاريع كثيره للسلطه
وللمجتمع الاهلي وبالتالي هذه حجه بصراحه
غير مقنعه وبعد ذلك استمعنا الى حجه اخرى
صادره عن مصدر امني ان هذا المال سياسي
وهذه تهمه مجرد تهمه لم يتم البرهنه عليها
لماذا لم يتم ابلاغ مؤسسه فلسطين بالاجراء
هي عرفت من البنك وليس من الجهه التي
اصدرت هذا القرار هذا يدل على ان هناك
شبهه
سياسيه موجوده وقائمه في هذا الاجراء
ونامل ان يتم يعني
توضيح الامر ومعالجه الامر جذريا لانه
يمكن ان يسجل نقطه سوداء اخرى في تاريخ
وسجل السلطه انا قلت ان هذا الاجراء كان
خاطئا عندما كان سلام فياض رئيسا للحكومه
لان هناك كان اغلاق لمؤسسات وكان هناك
اعتقالات على خلفيه سياسيه مثل ما يجري
الان وهناك ايضا مزيد من الامعان في نظام
فردي نحن عندنا المؤسسات تقريبا معطله الى
حد كبير المجلس التشريعي معطل المؤسسات لا
تقوم بدورها القضاء يعني عليه يعني ضروره
لاستقلال بشكل واضح حتى يقوم بدوره
المطلوب منه وضمانه من ضمانات الاساسيه
لحكم الشعب الفلسطيني كل هذه المسائل يعني
تجعلنا نقول ان الشبهه السياسيه يعني
محتمله ومحتمل جدا وعلينا ان نعالج ذلك
اذا كان هناك خلاف مع سلام فياض سياسي او
هناك شبهه بعلاقه بين سلام فياض ومحمد
دحلان فليتم النقاش من على هذه الارضيه
بدون ادخال المؤسسه في هذا الامر وا اتخاذ
الاجراء بالتحفظ على الحسابات ثم البحث عن
الدلائل نحن من حق النيابه العامه ان تحقق
ولكن عليها ان تحقق عندما يكون لديها ادله
او قرائن كافيه تستدعي التحقيق والا كل
شخص يمكن ان يوجه اتهامات لاي شخص او لاي
مؤسسه ويصبح عددا كبيرا من الفلسطينيين في
دائره الشبهه والاتهام هذه مسائل ذك على
ذكر الشبهه السياسيه التي اشرت اليها سيد
هاني المصري على ذكر الشبهه
السياسيه تبدو هي القضيه المفصليه في هذه
المساله رغم ما يبدو من عناوين اخرى نريد
ان نعرف بعد الفاصل الى اي مدى هناك
حسابات سياسيه وراء الخطوه التي جرت في
فلسطين الغد والى اي مدى هناك ربما مؤشرات
على تكتلات سياسيه الان تحاول ان تتبلور
ووراء هذه القضيه لنا عوده بعد فاصل نرجو
ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها قرار النيابه
العامه الفلسطينيه التحفظ على اموال جمعيه
فلسطين الغد الخيريه التابعه لرئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني السابق
سيد حسن
سليم رغم الجانب الذي تناولناه لحد ما
الموضوع الاجرائي او الاتهام الرسمي هناك
من يذهب الى القول
بان حقيقه ما يجري هو ان هناك صراع خفي
يجري لخلافه الرئيس محمود
عباس وان الكل يحاول ان يدعم نفسه
بمرتكزات ماليه او اقتصاديه او مشاريع هل
تعتقد بان الاجراء يدخل في هذا السياق
لدرء توجه من هذا
القبيل يعني يا سيدي حتى لو كان هناك حديث
عن موضوعه خلافه الرئيس محمود عباس او
هناك رغبه لدى كثيرين في خلافته ما علاقه
الدكتور سلام فياض بالخلافه الدكتور سلام
هو عضو مجلس تشريعي لكتله من عضوين
الدكتور سلام فياض حديث الوجود في البلد
ليس له عصابه ولا عشيره كبيره تدعمه وليس
له علاقه في اي صراع سابق الرجل دخل
باحترام الى العمل السياسي وخرج باحترام
لم يضع احد في حقه سلبيه واحده او شائبه
واحده الدكتور سلام هو شخص مهني او شخص
فني ليس له علاقه في الطموح الذي يجري
الحديث عنه بخلافه الرئيس ارى ان ما يجري
الحديث بشانه الفتره الحاليه وما سبق هو
محاوله زج او استخدام الدكتور سلام فياض
من قبل اخرين راغبين بالدخول لهذه الحلبه
هم لديهم الطموح وليس الدكتور سلام
فيضو كان تعليق الدكتور سلام تعليق رجل
دوله يعني هؤلاء الذين يختفون وراء سلام
فيض النقاش حولهم دكتور محمد
كريشان تفضل يعني السياسيون كثر اللاعبون
في الحلبه السياسيه كثر اصحاب المال
السياسي كثر ايضا سيد محمد كريشان يرغبون
بزج هذا الرجل الطيب الرجل الذي لا علاقه
له بالصراع السياسي من اجل اقحام في هذا
في هذا
الصراع فيما يتعلق بالاسماء الاسماء كثيره
والجزيره اكثر اكثر جهه تعث من هي الاسماء
ذات الرغبه والطموح الكبير بخلافه الرئيس
محمود عباس او تولي موقع ومنصب سياسي عادي
الحقيقه انتم ادرى نحن نحن لا نعرف كثرا
يفتض ان ت يتم معالجه الامور في اطار
الاجرائي نعم يفترض انكم انتم تعرفون اكثر
من ولهذا اسال سيد هاني المصري ربما ربما
يعلم هو اكثر مني ومنك سيد هاني المصري هل
هل تعتقد فعلا بانه يجري الزج الان بالسيد
سلم فيض مع انه اسمه على عكس ما قال سيد
سليم اسمه تردد اكثر من مره لخلافه الرئيس
محمود عباس ونظر على انه شخص يحظى برضا
المؤسسات الماليه الكبرى الدوليه وبرضا
واشنطن وحتى برضاء اسرائيل هذا الكل كلام
ك كان متداولا هل تعتقد ان له و وجاهه
معينه في هذا السياق الان ايه اولا علينا
ان نلاحظ ان النظام السياسي الفلسطيني يمر
بازمه عميقه جدا
وشامله في ظل فشل يعني المفاوضات وفي ظل
تعمق الاحتلال وتوسيع الاستيطان وفي ظل
استمرار الانقسام و خطر وصول حركه حماس
الى اتفاق مع اسرائيل يمكن ان يؤدي الى
تحويل الانقسام الى انفصال وبالتالي بدلا
من معالجه جذور هذه الازمه يتم يعني تفجير
نزاعات ثانويه بدلا من ان نتوحد في مواجهه
المخاطر الحقيقيه نلاحظ ان هناك انشغال
بمعارك زي مثلا معركه خلافه الرئيس من حق
سلام فياض ان يكون له طموح سياسي اذا كان
لديه طموح سياسي واسمه فعلا احد الاسماء
التي تتردد لخلافه الرئيس ابو مازن و
وهناك محاوله للربط ما بين سلام فياض
ومحمد دحلان ولعل هذا هو الذي يفسر ما
يجري سلام فياض ليس من الضروره ان يكون في
معسكر واحد مع دحلان ولكن هناك فوبيا
اسمها فوبيا محمد
دحلان نراها يعني موجوده وتطل براسها في
اكثر من م مره وفي اكثر من مجال من حق اي
انسان ان يطمح اذا ارتكب هذا الانسان
مخالفات قانونيه يجب محاسبته بشكل قانوني
يجب ان يكون هناك سياده للقانون يجب ان لا
يتم معالجه يعني اي انسان على خلفيه ارائه
او طموحه اذا عبر عن هذا الطموح بوسائل
مشروعه الانتخابات هي الوسيله التي يمكن
ان يتنافس فيها المرشحون على الرئاسه ولكن
الانتخابات يعني معطله وغير محدد متى يمكن
ان تجري وبالتالي هذا يؤزم الموقف اكثر
واكثر على كل المستويات
والاسعر ان يتم المسارعه بحل هذا الموضوع
و بتوضيح الاسباب الفعليه على الاقل بشكل
عام ومن الجهه التي اصدرت القرار وليس من
امني او غيره هذا الذي يجعلنا نتساءل
ويجعل الكثيرون يتساءلون لو كانت الامور
تجري بشكل قانوني كل انسان تحت القانون
سلام فياض ومؤسسه سلام فياض واي مؤسسه
اخرى لا احد فوق القانون ولكن على اساس
احترام يعني الحقوق واحترام القوانين وليس
على اساس انتهاك الحقوق وبالتالي استخدام
القانون لاهداف سياسيه وتال على ذكر
استخدام القانون سيد هاني المصري هل هل
تعتقد بانه هناك تخوف الان من ان ي يكبر
الموضوع لان المشاريع التي تقوم بها هذه
المؤسسه في مناطق سي وتشمل المناطق الاكثر
تهميشا في الضفه الغربيه وهناك ربما قد
يخلق نوع من التعطف من هؤلاء الاهالي
الذين تمتعوا بهذا النوع من المشاريع في
فلسطين
الغد نعم معك حق وانا قلت في البدايه ان
يعني تجميد الحسابات لمده مفتوحه يمكن ان
يؤدي الى انهيار المؤسسه وبالتالي تضرر
المستفيدين منها وهم يعني المشاريع التي
تنفذ في مناطق سي وفي البدو والقدس وهي في
مناطق حيويه وبحاجه الى هذه المشاريع وهذا
الامر
يستدعي رفع الحجز واستمرار الاجراءات
القانونيه لان الاستمرار بالحجز وخاصه
لمده غير محدده وهذا غير قانوني يؤدي الى
انهيار المؤسسه حتى لو صدر الحكم النهائي
بالبراءه تكون البراءه قد صدرت يعني وقتها
لا لا تنفع على الاطلاق والندم ساعتها
سيكون حيث لا ينفع الندم نحن نناشد الجميع
ارتفاع الى مستوى المصلحه الوطنيه
الارتفاع الى مستوى احترام حقوق الانسان
وسياده القانون ومعالجه الخلافات بطريقه
ديمقراطيه وشرعيه وليس عن طريق الضرب تحت
الحزام نعم ان ان تكون هذه القضيه سيد حسن
سليم في وقت فييه استقاله حكومه الحمد
الله في حديث عن هذه المفاوضات ال بين
حماس واسرائيل حول مستقبل غزه كما ينشر في
بعض
التقارير موضوع المصالحه هل تعتقد ان كل
هذا مرتبط ببعض
البعض يعني اعيد واؤكد مره اخرى يعني حظ
الدكتور سلام فياض حظ عافر جاء توقيت
الحجز على الاموال بموجب قرار قضائي في ظل
هذه الاحداث التي تفضلت وتحدثت عنها ولكن
لا علاقه ما بين المصالحه والتفاوض مع
اسرائيل واستقاله الدكتور رامي الحمد الله
وبين الحجز على اموال شركه فلسطين الغد ما
تفضل به الاستاذ هاني المصري في الحديث عن
سياره القانون الاصل ان يتم احترام
القرارات القضائيه اذا كان الحجز تم بموجب
قر قرار قضائي ما التعليق اذا لماذا
التعليق وبراك ما هو الاهم الحفاظ على
هيبه النظام السياسي وعلى الامن والنظام
العام في البلد وعلى التاكد من سلامه
ومشروعيه ومصادر الاموال والاهداف التي
تاتي من اجلها ام الاهم هو الحفاظ على
مشاريع صغيره تنفذها شركه فلسطين الغد
الدكتور سلام فياض مكت في رئاسه الوزراء
ست سنوات الم يكن الاجدر في دكتور سلام مع
كل التقدير والاحترام لجهوده ان يوجه
جهوده وانشطته وموازنات من اجل هذه
المناطق النائيه في مناطق جيم التي هي
احود ما تكون الى الضخ لتلك الاموال والى
انفاذ هذه المشاريع بدون شك حجز الاموال
سيؤثر على الشركه ولكن الاصل حتى نتاكد من
المشروعيه الانتظار
لحين صدور القرار النهائي والدكتور سلام
اليوم وامس صرح بانه سيتبع اجراءات
قانونيه من اجل الاستكمال بالتالي هو فضل
احترام القانون والقضاء الذي ساهم مساهمه
كبيره في بناءه من اجل الوصول الى نتيجه
عادله والقضاء فلسطيني اثبت غير مره بانه
نزيه ولا يتاثر بالاحداث المحيطه فيه نعم
سلام فياض لم يشاء الخوض ويبدو انه يراهن
على الاجراءات القانونيه ولكن على صفحته
الرسميه في موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
فيسبوك نشر قبل قليل هذه الايه الكريمه
اما الزبد فيذهب جفا جفاء واما ما ينفع
الناس فيمكث في الارض هل لديك
اي تحليل لهذه الايه لان التحليل الفقهي
ليس من اختصاصنا هل لديك اي تحليل سياسي
ان يستشهد بهذه
الايه يعني غير متاكد ان الدكتور سلام
فياض هو من نشر هذه الايه لمعرفتي بخلفيه
الدكتور سلام فياض فهو ليس امام مسجد ولا
واعظ في وزاره الاوقاف حتى يتم انتقاء هذه
الايه بعنايه بالتاكيد حوله كثير من
المستشارين ذات الرغبه بتضخيم هذه القضيه
وكان الموضوع نكايه بالدكتور سلام فياض او
بشركه فلسطين الغد الكتور دتور فياض صرح
كما ذكرت امس واليوم وانا من الذين
احترموا هذا التوجه بالانتظار لحين صدور
قرار قضائي نهائي ومن ثم ستظهر الحقيقه لا
احد يطعن في نزاهه وشفافيه الدكتور سلام
فياض كما ذكرت امضى فتره طويله في رئاسه
الوزراء ولكنه في النهايه بشر يخطئ ويصيب
ومن حق القضاء ومن حق القانون ان ياخذ
مجراه لا يوجد فوق القانون احد سواء كان
رئيس وزراء او رئيس او وزير الكل تحت
القانون ويفترض ان يكون اك اكثر الناس حرص
على انفاذ القانون هو الدكتور سلام فياض
لخلفيته السياسيه والمهنيه وللدور الذي
لعبه على مدار ست سنوات الماضيه شكرا
جزيلا لك الكاتب والمحلي السياسي حسن سليم
من نابلس وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من رام الله
هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات لابحاث
السياسات وبهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه
الله والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا